blade explain what we're doing today
today we're not playing through console
we're playing through a Samsung
television all right so we just go to
the Xbox app this is all about uh
cleaning stuff wait the game is now
we're going to clean the car yeah and
after this we're going to play fix that
toilet 7 000. there you go you just want
to clean the whole thing you go up and
down with the right stick
the right stick goes up in there and you
got different nozzles if you want to hit
the top buttons uh I don't understand it
Milton clean your room God damn mother
I'm virtually cleaning a car I don't own
for no money so his next game is called
a plague tail Requiem oh no
that's a stupid amount of rats oh no you
gotta wait like that one you gotta run
all right
oh no I went into the rest why did I go
into the rats
that's a lot of rats okay so we're gonna
run from the rats
good idea you're gonna run towards us
when we get get up here we go run okay
go run away I mean run away okay so not
towards us I'm gonna wait I'm in a way